you know I often speak about an
innovation ecosystem and and I say that
there are four key things that such an
ecosystem has to possess the first is
strategic focus and that strategic focus
can be a national strategic focus which
is one I like to talk about a lot it can
be within the context of a given
enterprise but strategic focus thinking
about you know what the big issues are
what the big challenges are where the
big trends are where is the world going
what are the great things we need to
think about it's always important
because it helps to sort of size the
problem as it were or spur the dream but
then we get nowhere if we don't have
discovery if we don't have
transformative ideas and that is where
basic research and freeing people to
think about things in a very creative
way leads to you know aha moments that
we we don't anticipate that's what makes
them aha moment so we have to have and
appreciate the power of transformative
ideas and set the conditions for that to
happen but ideas are not enough
everybody has an idea the real issue is
if one has something that is really
important that is potentially
transformative how does one get it into
the marketplace how does one get it into
practice and and that is is difficult it
requires translational pathways that
ironically in some of the newer arenas
are not so easy it's not just soak
simple as pure venture capital and a lot
of the venture capital and early
investors want to have more proof of
concept and then proof of scale and so
there is a kind of patient capital that
needs to exist that perhaps in the right
circumstances if it really involves some
breakthrough technology that may be
broadly transforming
as opposed to the province of one
enterprise maybe the government has to
support some of that and then the final
key element is capital but when people
think of capital they tend to think of
financial capital and it is one key
element of capital financial capital
patient capital but then there's also
what I refer to as infrastructural
capital and then of course there's human
capital infrastructure capital relates
to the fact that if one is in some new
area like nanotechnology again some
areas of biotechnology really
breakthrough arenas there may need to be
shared infrastructure for test beds for
scale-up demonstrations for prototyping
main it may need computational
capabilities for modeling and simulation
that a start-up firm cannot afford and
so they have to be mechanisms to provide
that kind of capital a kind of
infrastructure for those enterprises and
then human capital we've already been
discussing in discussing the quiet
crisis because if we don't have the
people there are no transformative ideas
if we don't have the people there's no
one to either create or move along
translational pathways and if we don't
have the people then the other capital
doesn't matter because there won't be
anything to invest it in anyway